[Music]
the legendary rock band The Eagles is
suing a hotel in Mexico for using the
same name as its iconic song Hotel
California the band filed a trademark
infringement lawsuit against the Hotel
California in Baja the lawsuit says the
band has no connection to the hotel and
it also claims that the tourist
destination is using the Eagles classic
hit to mislead customers Carter Evans is
outside the hotel that is actually
associated with the famous tune that is
the Beverly Hills Hotel in Beverly Hills
California Carter good morning good
morning that's right this is actually
the hotel on the cover of that mega hit
1976 album Hotel California but when the
Mexican state of Baja had its own Hotel
California while the eagle swooped right
in with a lawsuit
there's plenty of room at the Hotel
California
but not apparently if you're misleading
consumers are selling unauthorized
branded merchandise that's the gist of
an 11-page lawsuit filed this week by
the Eagles against Hotel California AHA
in Mexico
according to the suit defendants lead US
consumers to believe that the hotel is
associated with the Eagles and among
other things served as the inspiration
for the lyrics in Hotel California which
is false Gayle King spoke with Eagle Don
Henley last year about where the song's
inspiration came from and it's not
really about California it's about
America you know it's about the dark
underbelly of the American Dream it's
about excess the group says the Baja
hotel is now making excessive use of the
words Hotel California
Melissa Doug addo is a trademark and
copyright attorney they're alleging a
couple things the first thing is that
the hotel is actually advertised in a
manner to create confusion in the minds
of consumers about the hotel being
affiliated with the band the Eagles the
[Music]
hotel's website references specific
lyrics in the song Hotel California is
accessed by driving down a long desert
highway and mission bells are heard
daily online reviews seem to corroborate
the band's claim the famous song by the
Eagles lured us here and the song made
this into a popular place and it's
interesting to tour those online reviews
that show actual confusion are very
significant and when you have real
evidence from real consumers that is
really terrific evidence also included
in the Eagles complaint the baja hotels
sale of merchandise like shirts caps and
keychains with the words hotel
california a phrase the band claims it
owns the legal rights to more than a
year ago the hotel filed for trademarks
for nearly 200 more Hotel California
products everything from fragrances to I
wear in bedspreads so I think that's the
reason for the swift action and the very
serious action that they've taken in
this lawsuit
well the BAA hotel told us it would have
no official comment until it answers
this
complaint but on its website it states
the owners do not have any affiliation
with the Eagles nor do they have any
association or promote any association
gail whatever the outcome it's a really
good song Thank You Carter